So Leute, heute ist es soweit, Windows 11 ist am Start
und ich dachte mir, nachdem ich habe gestern schon ein Video zugemacht, nachdem es gestern
nicht ganz die richtige Version war, die ich hatte, ich hatte sogar eine noch neuere Version
im Hintergrund von meinem Video gezeigt, dachte ich mir, wir gucken uns das heute einfach
noch mal zusammen an und wir können uns eine Runde CAC W'n über Windows.
Mal kann man Battlefield spielen, äh morgen ab, keine Ahnung, müssen wir mal schauen,
laut hier, schauen wir mal, äh Battlefield 2042 Beta CEST, Beta Schedule bei Windows
Central, äh, ja, Early Access Beta Starts, startet das verdammte Spiel, ich will nicht,
dass es lädt, wenn es lädt dann, was war das, dann stürzt es ab, ach, der echte Gangster
war seiner Zeit einfach voraus, der echte Gangster, ich sag's euch Leute, der echte
Gangster, wäre er heute auf YouTube, also wäre er jetzt in dem Alter heute und wäre
auf YouTube, hätte er angefangen, der hätte 5 Millionen Abos, 9 Uhr, ey, Moment, 9 AM,
das ist morgen, das ist 9 Uhr, morgen sehe ich das richtig, wirklich, normalerweise fangen
die Dinge immer sonst mal an bei uns, Moment, ich muss gerade mal kurz gucken, ne, ne, ne,
ne, ne, ne, Early Stream gar nicht, ich muss morgen arbeiten, ich muss mal kurz gucken,
bis wann ich die NDA unterschrieben hab, wo ich nichts sagen darf, lulululululu, by the
Aber ich habe übrigens 5 Battlefield Beta Codes, ich habe mir überlegt, vielleicht
soll ich die im Stream verlosen oder auf Twitter.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, bis wann das NDA geht, Sekunde, ich blicke gerade nicht durch.
Hat irgendjemand, meine ganz andere Frage, hat irgendjemand von der Gamescom was dieses
Jahr mitbekommen?
Die war ja wohl, aber es hat wirklich absolut keinen Geschlechtsteil interessiert, also
es ergibt allgemein gesagt keinen Senderspruch, es hat keine Sau interessiert, oder?
Moment, bis wann habe ich NDA, vielleicht darf ich ja jetzt schon was zu erzählen.
Mein Gott ey, die Mails von die ey, ich finde den Kram immer nicht, hier NDA-Unterschrift
bis, fuck, bis morgen um neun, na super, das heißt ich darf bis morgen um neun nichts erzählen.
Exzellent, top, dachte eigentlich ich hätte morgen noch in Ruhe Zeit was aufzunehmen,
dann muss ich das heute Abend noch machen.
So meine ersten Eindrücke, na gut, egal, also, dann, ab morgen neun Uhr geht's los.
Sag einfach du hast die AIN, das würde eventuell sogar funktionieren, aber ich hab ja nicht
Angst, dass sie mich verklagen deswegen, sondern im Zweifelsfall darf ich nie wieder zu irgendwelchen
Events, das ist vielleicht auch nicht so sinnvoll.
Also morgen neun Uhr, das ist halt so früh, was ist denn mit denen los, warum geht das
denn so früh los?
Das sind ja richtig EU-freundliche Zeiten, alter was ist denn jetzt los hier, meine Güte
hier, Baby Clocks hat Zaps gegiftet, fünf Stück, dankeschön, wer hat da was gekriegt
und wer hat gedodged ist die Frage, denn die meisten haben gedodged, Build-SY, Gamepad,
Paste-WR, Trollkirche und Newt Twitch, noch mehr, jetzt ist aber mal gut hier, jetzt ist
der Baby Houdini am Start mit fünf Skifted Zaps, danke, danke Leute hier, geht's aber
ab, Bombtag 1, Prime Sub auch, dankeschön, wir hatten hier was gekriegt, Bindstrike, mal
ausnahmsweise nicht gedodged, sonst bist du immer gut dabei, was zusammen geht, ne, Metvai
Kreativi Adonis Adipos, alles klar, also der fette Adonis sozusagen, die Kurve ist auch
am Start, exzellent Leute hier, danke für die Subs, was ist denn halt los, 52 Milliarden
jetzt, danke, danke Leute, heute ist aber richtig, richtig, geht's rein heute, ok, also,
wir gucken uns heute die Windows 11 Release Version an, richtig Scamtrain, guck mal hier
Level 4 Jebait Scamastrain, übrigens wisst ihr was ich super finde, also man sieht schon
auch auf YouTube, dass es wirklich Sinn macht, was, ah, vielleicht soll ich mich auch selbst
mal richtig schreiben, man sieht schon, dass es durchaus Sinn macht was zu aktuellen Themen
aufzunehmen, ich hab selten innerhalb von einem Tag 34.000, es sind mittlerweile ja glaube
ich sogar schon 36.000 intern, ich hab vorhin mal, und Views an einem Tag, das ist selten,
das hatte ich doch nicht immer zu Call of Duty Zeiten, das ist selten, das ist, lohnt
sich, lohnt sich, was waren das für Vorschläge bei Google, ich weiß nicht, ich hab mich vertippt
und dann kamen irgendwie so merkwürdige Sachen raus, keine Ahnung, das Scamtrain, na komm,
vielleicht kriegen wir den 5, vielleicht kriegen wir Level 5, Level 5 hatten wir bestimmt
schon ein halbes Jahr nicht mehr, lasst euch in die Abo-Falle loggen, dann dürft ihr auch
in meine WhatsApp-Gruppe, ich bekomme, genau, Snapchat gibt es, was verspricht man denn
den Leuten heute so, dass die, dass sie subscriben, exklusiven OnlyFans-Access, bei OnlyFans ist
ja auch schon out, Leute, jetzt übertreibts, übertreibts nicht, ich muss ja heute nur
ein bisschen schibähen und schon gibt es mega, mega Subs hier, danke Leute, was haben wir
gesagt, Zach Winn, subscribt, Tinity, 5 Monate, huge subscriptions hier und jetzt kommt der Baby
Clocks noch mal mit 5 Stück, für den Phipps, den hab ich schon öfters gesehen, der hat
es auf jeden Fall verdient, der hat sonst noch was gekriegt, TrinsicGG, Madhawks, Fullmetal
Stench, Sirius67, August, subscription, meine Güte, jetzt ist ja mal gut, jetzt übertreibts
meine ich hier, komm mal, wir haben jetzt den Scamtrain Level 5 voll, das reicht, ich mache
euch einen Vorschlag, ich mache euch einen Vorschlag, wie viele Subs sind es jetzt über
100 überdings, ich mache euch einen Vorschlag, Frage, was haltet ihr davon, ich lese gleich
den recht durch, Twitter, ich spende ab und zu immer ein bisschen Geld an die Katzenhilfe
in Karlsruhe, sieht man öfters auf Twitter, wenn ich was schreibe, ich werde auch einfach,
weil ich so viele Subs jetzt gekriegt habe, ich gifte jeden Sub, den ich ab jetzt noch
bekomme, gifte ich an die Katzenhilfe Karlsruhe, wenn ihr keine Katzen mögt, dann subscribt
einfach nicht, oder lasst es generell bleiben, weil es so viele wie heute schon gesagt haben,
ich bin ja komplett schon wieder Big Stonks Money, ja das mache ich, also sollte wirklich
noch irgendjemand seinen Prime Sub übrig haben, dann geht das heute an die Katzenhilfe
Karlsruhe, so, also, wen haben wir denn hier noch am Start, der Babyglox hat wieder gegiftet
ohne Ende, LittleGegi ist auch am Start mit 5 Gifted Subs, wir hatten was gekriegt, hier
Dankeschön für die Subs, RightKill, Crytek, Avus, Underscore, Underscore, Underscore ist
wichtig, Dark's League, Killfil, den habe ich auch schon öfters gesehen, dann hat der
BabyHoodin nochmal gegiftet, 5-Stripped, Abaddon44, RealSNX, Wingreed, Voutz, Tronic,
DragonPlayer32, Angel für die Subs, richtig Scamtrain hier am Start, ich sehe es schon,
so ab hier gibt es jetzt, ab hier wird gespendet, so Babyglox, auch das sage ich es, der hat
es definitiv verdient, der ist so oft da und so lange hier schon gewesen, weiß gar nicht
ob der jemals so subscribt hat, aber auf jeden Fall der hat es mehr als verdient, der ist
so oft am Start hier, ich muss mir das übrigens mal aufschreiben, sonst weiß ich nicht ab
wann ich mit dem, wann es los ging, kann ich in der History nachgucken, Karlsruhe, ja,
Mechvamburino, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub, meine Güte heute, heute geht es aber echt
zur Sache, dabei wollte ich mir einfach noch Windows 11 angucken, nochmal hier, der MichiLensMS
kriegt auch was, ja der, heute wollt ihr es wissen, jetzt kommt Wolle604105, Gifted Subs,
die Kräuterzigarette hat was gekriegt, McPappy95, Ande, 7zt, Rainsil, 13EEF, Elite, richtig
Massive Pog, ist das der ChainLore, ich erkenne es nicht, aber hier Massive japanische Schriftzeichen,
danke für den Sub Leute hier, auch hier Wolle für die 5 Gifted Subs, hast du die neuen
C++ Updates bereits gesehen, ja habe ich gesehen, will ich nicht besprechen im Stream, nice,
ok wann gibt es Battlefield, morgen gibt es Battlefield, ich wusste nicht, dass das Battlefield,
dass die Beta schon um 9 Uhr anfängt, sonst hätte ich das Video fertig machen müssen,
das muss ich heute Abend noch irgendwie machen, also ich kann, also kann ich, ich kann bloß
2 Stunden streamen Leute, dann muss ich noch ein Battlefield Video aufnehmen, null, wo
ist eigentlich der CuteMod, ja das frage ich mich auch, der ist so lang, preload, ja, ja,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen wird es hier nicht angezeigt, aber ja ich hab schon preloaded,
ja Windows Suche kannst du eh knicken, schön, dass du deinen Weg hierher gefunden hast,
Baby Orca, nice, so jetzt können wir, jetzt können wir einfach anfangen, das Scam Train
ist heute richtig krass am Start gewesen, weiß auch nicht, wo sind wir denn, mal gucken
wie viel Kohle wir schon gesammelt haben für die, das hatten wir, das hatten wir schon,
ab hier hab ich gesagt fang ich an oder, nee ab wo hab ich gesagt, ich hab's mir aufgeschrieben,
doch ab hier genau, also sie kriegen schon mal 5 Euro, 10 Euro, weil ich krieg ja nur
noch 2 Euro, null W alter, Besos, direkt, direkt in Besos überwiesen hier, 10 Euro
haben wir schon mal, ich glaub die kriegen am Ende ein bisschen was, nice, Besos braucht
es auch dringend, dringend, der braucht mehr Raketen, muss man mehr Leute ins Weltall schicken
und generell gehts ihm ganz schlecht, so auf gehts, richtig Pock, also, hat Windows 11
wirklich zu 25%, wirklich kann jetzt glaub ich noch kaum einer beantworten, aber das
hab ich auch gelesen, ich persönlich tippe drauf, dass alles beim Alten bleibt für 99%
der Anwendung, gibt bestimmt ein paar Produkte wo es besser läuft, ein paar wo es schlechter
läuft, aber im Großen und Ganzen wirst du wahrscheinlich keinen wahnsinnigen Unterschied
ermerken, jetzt ist gut, jetzt es reicht, es ist genug jetzt, sonst komm ich ja heute
zu nix, danke für den Sub, so, also, damit wir Windows 11 testen können, müssen wir
erstmal das Windows 11 ISO runterladen, so, und jetzt passt mal auf, what, a silenced
request was sent, but no user is signed in, wie wärs denn wenn ihr mir dann einfach die
normale Seite zeigt anstatt einen silenced request, what the fuck wollen die von mir,
alter Microsoft, ok, Windows 11 download, wir machen das einfach mal über Incoctito Tab,
guck mal da ist es doch schon, download, zack, jetzt herunterladen, erstellen von Installationsassistent,
herunterladen eines Windows 11 Anträgeimages, Moment das geht jetzt direkt, ernsthaft, haha,
nee, doch, wie das geht jetzt, das ist ja mal, das ist ja mal eine riesen Verbesserung
zu Windows 10, bei Windows 10 ging das nicht, wenn du nämlich sagst Windows 10 ISO download,
richtig massive, guck mal, wenn du sagst Windows 10, Windows 10 ISO download, dann kannst du
nicht, dann kannst du nicht dieses dumme Tool runterladen oder sowas, der Babyglock schon
wieder rot, wieder tot, 22 Abos hat er schon gegiftet, ich weiß nicht, was ich sagen soll,
aber hat einer richtig viel Kohle locker, wie es aussieht und möchte Amazon unterstützen
und mich natürlich auch, hoffe ich mal, danke für die Subs, alles, Leute, und es gibt ja
Trick 17, das zeige ich jedes Mal, weil es der Chat immer so geil findet, Monatsanfang
kam heute gehalten wahrscheinlich, eigentlich nur mich, es gab ja den Trick für die Windows
10 ISO, man geht hier einfach auf die Settings für die Mobile Seite und dann refresht man
die Seite und man konnte bei Windows 10 auch einen ISO downloaden, das zeige ich jedes
Mal und der Chat ist immer ganz furchtbar begeistert, dass es so easy geht.
Warum ist Chrome blau, weil das kein richtiger Chrome ist, sondern ein Chromium, das ist
quasi Chrome mit ein paar Google Bestandteilen raus und nochmal neu kompiliert, ehrlich gesagt
hat es überhaupt keinen Sinn das zu verwenden, kein großartigen.
Kann man die Thematik der nicht unterstützten CPUs umgehen und Windows 11 dort still installieren?
Ja, kannst du machen, Microsoft behält sich aber bei so einer Installation vor, dass es
keine Updates gibt, ob die das machen werden glaube ich nicht, weil Microsoft ist eh schon
ziemlich erpicht darauf, dass jeder Updates bekommt, selbst weil Microsoft verteilt Updates
an Leute, die offensichtlich gecrackte Windows Version verwenden, also ich glaube nicht,
dass wenn sie eine andere Möglichkeit haben, das einstellen, glaube ich nicht, aber ja
das geht.
So, also wir laden uns erstmal das ISO runter, Produkt, Spracheauswahl, Englisch, International,
so bestätigen, Link valid, ok schön, ach hier, also ich kann mir nicht helfen, ich
finde die Seiten von Microsoft unglaublich unintuitiv aufgebaut, ich habe den Download-Knopf
gar nicht gesehen, aber wahrscheinlich lag das an mir, ihr habt es bestimmt gleich gesehen.
Hast du schon Windows 11, ne, da hat mir gerade das ISO erst runter, oh habe ich genug Plattenplatz,
Windows 11 ist hier, warum installiert Windows schon wieder irgendeinen Shit auf meinem
Rechner, gehst du mal weg, zauerei, dann vergesse ich mal, ich wollte gucken, ob ich genug Plattenplatz
habe, ja mein Plattenplatz ist ein bisschen eng gerade, ja für das ISO reicht es noch,
14G hier, auf D habe ich genug Platz, das ist aber eine Magnetplatte, die SSDs sind
noch ein bisschen voll, ich brauche Platz morgen für Battlefield Gameplays, fuck, ich
muss gerade mal kurz PN beantworten, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
thematisch nicht so wirklich zum stream aus dem weiß ich nicht was ich machen will gibt es
battlefield streams ich werde erstmal ein bisschen alleine spielen aber dann mache ich auf jeden
fall ein stream ich spiele das auf jeden fall ein paar runden hier im stream zusammen je nachdem
ob ich instant abgefuckt bin oder nicht also download zack zack bevor wir überhaupt windows 11
installieren können ich kenne mich da ein bisschen mit aus weil ich habe die ganze zeit hier schon
eine testinstallation am start bevor wir windows 11 installieren können muss man erst ein paar
dinger machen damit das funktioniert unten per powershell was orschell wo ist das per powershell
what ein hasch der iso ich vertraue microsoft dass es ein richtiges iso ist muss da kein ich
muss da kein kein kein md5 somit rüber machen oder nie md5 macht man nicht mehr schar 256 auf
der anderen seite ich habe noch nie mit powershell getfile das probieren wir jetzt aus leute das
probieren wir jetzt aus ich habe noch nie in powershell den hasch gemacht für ein fall get
was getfile hasch what the fuck getfile hasch ok zack bamm das ist wenigstens mal ganz gut benannt
ich meine md5 somit immer noch kürzer fallen mit tab tab sollte das tcp zeug nicht dafür sorgen
dass die iso heile ankommt doch der sinn von haschwerten ist in dem fall gar nicht zu überprüfen
ob die doch auch zu überprüfen ob die übertragung korrekt gewesen ist aber viel eher ob das was du
runtergeladen hast auch dem entspricht was der hersteller anbieten möchte ja das stimmt md5
ist nicht mehr ist ist nicht mehr sicher für also es ist jetzt sehr schlimm wenn du md5 verwendest
für irgendwelche custom sachen um downloads zu überprüfen aber ich würde es nicht machen zu
mal die wenigsten noch md5 zum bereitstellen so also was haben wir hier schar 256 englisch
international brauchen wir also was haben wir in b 11 englisch international iso b 117 fe b 117 fe
scheint zu funktionieren richtiger hasch poc wir können es wahrscheinlich sogar copy paste dann
können wir das ausblicken wir haben die richtige iso hier hätte man gar nicht gerechnet also was
man machen muss damit man bin aus 11 in der vm betreiben kann richtig poc ist folgendes man muss
ich kann es jetzt mal hier anhand dieser windows server vm machen die verwenden wir jetzt einfach
dafür weil jetzt brauche ich eh nicht mehr weiß gar nicht warum ich in der windows server vm
überhaupt habe wahrscheinlich wollte ich mich persönlich eine runde extrem paint champen
weil warum man freiwillig windows server macht weiß ich also er kriegt mal ordentlich speicher
die vm erstmal fette 16 g ram 4 cpu kerne 16 g ssd iso brauchen wir iso windows international
so und damit das ganze ich benenne das mal umsonst finde ich das nachher im leben nicht wieder win
elf release damit man das ganze in der vm starten kann muss man folgendes machen also als erstes
muss man in die options gehen und sagen access control enable encryption dann vergibt man ein
super secure password zum beispiel 1 2 3 4 5 6 und sagt encrypt wusstest du
warum hatten das hier funktioniert wo liegt hier meine festplatte
60 g ok ab mal wo liegt die die liegt e doppelpunkt vms und die liegt
und die liegt e doppelpunkt vms wie viel platz habe ich denn da noch fall warum braucht der
80 zack zack wie viel platz habe ich da 62 ja geil kann ich da irgendwas löschen was
haben wir hier bettel net was ist da drin bestimmt ja blo oder sowas jawohl komm hier
beim weg bdo weg also nix mit renew folder den brauche ich poe recordings da darf ich nicht
reingucken nicht wegen dem was ihr denkt sondern weil er sachen drin sind nicht sein steam library
wie groß sind das wobei ich glaube das reicht schon wenn ich das eine ich das eine lösche
so wie viel platz haben wir jetzt 89 bm easy aber platz immer da also highly secure password
vergeben 1 2 3 4 5 6 encrypt und jetzt erstmal 1 2 minuten das geht relativ schnell auch
wenn es nicht so aussieht ich habe das gestern mit anderen vm gemacht einfach kurz warten
und däumchen drehen es geht also es sieht es sieht langsamer aus als es ist es geht
dann relativ zackig oder auch nicht aber unter 60 g kann ich nix machen unter 60 g ist wenn
es installiert und und gleich ripp was ist die mindeste installation für mindeste installation
sein windows 11 mini momen storage oder sowas at least 64 g available oh nee hoffentlich
dachte es mir bei der installation nicht die können sich installieren weil so 60 g ist
da müssen wir jetzt durch also nur 10 minuten schwätzen dann ist es fertig ich habe gestern
die andere vm encrypted das ist auch eine 60 g festplatte gewesen das hat keine ahnung
fünf minuten gedauert so wenn man das gemacht hat muss man tpm hinzufügen und wenn man
tpm hinzugefügt hat dann muss man cq boot aktivieren und wenn man cq boot aktiviert
hat dann kann man windows installieren wieso ist windows so riesig das musst du microsoft
fragen windows ist anscheinend ja gar nicht so groß wir gucken mal danach was belegt ist
erinnert mich mal dran gleich ich schreibe mir das mal kurz auf was ist belegt auf platte
wir gucken mal was danach belegt ist nach der frischen installation wenn du auf deinem
desktop mit steuerung und maus da draußen hast du noch mehr platz für unordnung ja das
macht nichts das macht nichts das muss so bleiben das muss so was und sehe ich das ja
gar nicht mehr guck mal sonst erkenne ich das nicht das muss schon das muss schon so bleiben
wie es ist aber übrigens was mich auch immer fertig macht das windows je nach vergrößerungsstufe
nicht in der lage ist transparenten background mehr zu rendern das ist das ist wirklich
cac windows warum auch immer das leuchtet mir nicht ein das ist wirklich hier man versteht
es nicht so genau da fehlt ein stückchen von der katz irgendwie so was wollte ich jetzt
sagen das triggert die leute ja immer wenn ich das hier im stream zeige ich weiß dass
das geht dass man noch mehr drauf legen kann es gibt allerdings ein problem wenn man den
windows desktop zu voll macht dann wird dann nicht nur der desktop langsam sondern wenn
man den explorer auf macht dann geht sogar der explorer langsam auf was wirklich was
wirklich extremster pains gem ist wenn man sich überlegt dass ein voller desktop zum
slowdown im windows explorer führen kann ist halt absolut lächerlich ich weiß nicht
was microsoft wieder treibt man könnte auch mal den desktop aufräumen nee warum sollte
man das denn machen du kannst das du kannst das mit deinem desktop ja machen wir müssen
wir machen jetzt nicht das übliche das übliche ist sagt mir eine sache auf einem desktop
ich finde sie sofort aber da wissen wir ja dass es funktioniert das haben wir schon oft
genug gemacht du hast kein tpm chip in meinem pc ja dann installiert in a vm in a vm ist
ein software tpm glaube ich ok
systemsteuerung brauche ich keinen desktop für
ah was habe ich jetzt gerade geöffnet habe ich will es nicht öffnen das kennt ihr das
ihr bekommt was angezeigt ihr wollt enter drücken und dann ihr wollt enter drücken
ich kann nicht schreiben alter korn troll ihr wollt enter drücken da kommt was anderes
das ist das ist so hart hat sie bait und und wisst ihr wisst ihr wo mich das auch immer
übel triggert das ist bei bei google auf dem smartphone das kann man glaube ich das kann
man glaube ich auf f nicht ah ich bin übrigens der friseur by the way das kann man im google
desktop gar nicht so sehr zeigen aber ich versuche es mal in der smartphone übersicht
ja und ich wirklich gut google hat das nämlich auch das klappt dann manchmal dann suchst
du auf dem smartphone und manchmal klappt hier dann was aus so dinger hier und du klickst
dann auf einmal auf sachen drauf wo du überhaupt nicht draufklicken willst ganz schlimm kannst
du ausstellen ja möglich möglich aber es ist schon mal nervig dass es überhaupt an
ist oh leute wir brauchen windows key ein windows cd key ich habe ich habe den windows key einen
gültigen windows key der ist aber auf der alten installation drauf muss ich erst mal
gucken wie man den auslöser auslesen kann und wenn ich den auslese muss ich gucken dass
der stream chat ihn ich sieht weil sonst machen wir glaube ich den baros volumenlizenz voll
das ist wobei ich glaube nee das war glaube ich gar nicht so baus volumenlizenz leaket
ja mal gucken versucht das gleich auszulehnen brauchst keinen key na doch ich brauche key
weil ich will mir ein bisschen die custom als option angucken dass sie baro ist nie da
du meinst weil er nicht da ist weil er nicht da ist können wir können wir ruhig sein geld
verbraten oder was ja gute idee chat excellent ich sehe ich sehe schon der chat wie immer
absolut selbstlos kümmert sich um andere
eigentlich für den sub nicht aussprechbarer name hier steht name dabei sehr an fünf monate
zwei monate streak du hast jetzt einen silber keks dadurch dass du drei monate am stück
dabei bist über drei monate am stück dabei bist die findet ihr eigentlich neuen batches
also ich finde die sind echt nice geworden trinsic hat den holz keks weil es erst ein
monat dabei woitzer schlucker das ist irgendwas bayerisches danke für den sub die sind richtig
nice das ist mir zu viel 8bit kirby gerade richtig pock ne richtig pock übrigens danke
leute für die ganzen subs nummer so disclaimer sagt jetzt mal falls das jemand nicht will
auch wenn ich mir nicht vorstellen kann aber man weiß ja nicht kann er sein nachdem ich
so voll gespermt wurde mit subs heute am anfang habe ich sagt alles subs die nach den initialen
subs kommen gehen heute an die katzenhilfe karls ruhe die brauchen nämlich immer ein
bisschen geld sei es für futter sei es für irgendwelche utensilien oder sonst was generell
haben die nie genug geld und es trifft jetzt nicht nur das trifft jetzt nicht nur die katzenhilfe
karls ruhe das trifft natürlich auf alle zu das heißt wenn ihr bei euch lokal irgendein
tierheim habt oder irgendwelche leute die sich um kratzen müssen nicht kratzen sein
es gibt ja auch so igelstationen und sowas in der richtung gibt es ja jede menge geschichten
wenn euch da was dran liegt dann könnt ihr euch ja mal gedanken darüber machen ob ihr
da dran spendet jetzt nicht explizit nur an die hier sondern auch am besten bei euch lokal
was nein das bin ich immer noch nicht weil dann wisst ihr auch wo es ankommt muss aber
jeder selbst wissen danke für die subs leute hier ignt 2k50 das ist schon ein bisschen
älter das ist ja fast schon justin tv account wenn er wirklich von 2015 ist demischko danke
für den zapp den haben wir hier dein chi und hier der woizer schlugger
so haben wir jetzt encrypt wir haben encrypt ok encryption ist durch mr.
harthorst 123 123 456 dann hast du mein passport hier drin so was man jetzt machen muss ist
man geht hierhin sagt add tpm trusted platform module stimmt justin tv war 2013 ja ist recht
justin platform module und danach musste noch hierhin und sagen enable secure boot und wenn
man das alles gemacht hat dann kann man winos 10 in der vm winos 11 in der vm installieren
bisch 923 dankeschön für den zapp own3d war der shit erinnere mich nicht daran die hatten
ja verdrege mit deutschen streamer und dann haben deutsche streamer teilweise gestreamt
auf all auf own3d mit irgendwie 20 zuschauer oder so weil die seite keiner benutzen wollte
und waren froh alle dass sie nach dass sie zu twitch konnten ok installieren wir den kampel
mal fullscreen jetzt ist ja mal gut hier ist ja mal gut heißt jetzt ist baby clocks genug
jetzt hier nexon auch danken für den zapp 27 gegifte des zapps hat er schon der baby
clocks wir hatten jetzt wieder glück gehabt massif 31 hat was gekriegt jim jim der sagt
mir der name was er ist auch öfters am start larry schermer foodtaker ich hab winos noch
nicht mal installiert und es ist schon kaputt
ach ne das ist die vorher installierte ne ne ich weiß woran es liegt ja da kann winos
gar nix für comando zurück da kann winos nix für das ist das vorher schon installierte
winos server 2000 21 ich muss ich muss ja ins boot menü ich muss ins boot menü und
booten hier von cd auswählen deswegen ging das jetzt nicht booten von cd alles klar booten
von cd ok any key
das winos was du über wsl gelöscht hast genau das ist das kaputte winos 2000 winos
was war das 2020 2022 server ich blicke da aber winos version nicht durch was ich was
ich über wsl gelöscht habe genau kein wunder dass es nicht bootet so also wir wollen installieren
aber ich mach mal kurz hier also ein bisschen besser was sieht stretch toll dass das immer
noch standardmäßig in 4 zu 3 läuft lull language install englisch time and currency nein german
ganda ganz bestimmt german germany ja alles klar next install das ist immer noch der
vista installer oder es sieht also vielleicht nicht ganz aber es sieht immer noch hart nach
dem vista installer aus so ich versuche jetzt mal ich versuche mal ob ich ach komm wir installieren
es erstmal die lizenz kann ich nachher noch recover ich habe kein product key kann man
ja nachher noch eingeben so wir wollen pro was ist in der unterschied zwischen pro und
pro n pro n ist ohne edge und und und und zeug oder ohne edge und wir was und was sonst noch
ohne bloat das glaube ich nicht das ist winos das ist bestimmt nicht ohne bloat installieren
das ist normal ich will microsoft bloat haben so next next hab ich schon dran erinnert als
ich das erste mal ihr könnt euch schon vorstellen das ist ja ganz immer leer als ich das erste
mal mit meinem vater winos installiert habe da hat er wirklich da gesessen und hat angefangen
den lizenzvertrag zu scrollen und ich habe daneben gesagt man die ganze zeit gesagt als
drück weiter drück weiter das liest doch kein metal moment moment erst mal durch scroll
durch scroll durch scroll aber es hat er eingesehen nach einer halben minute dass er das nicht
durchlesen will zumal ich weiß nicht wieso seine englisch englisch reading skills sind
so upgrade install custom install advanced ja ich muss erstmal wenn warum hat winos
nicht den knopf einfach komplett drüber installieren ich mein sogar ubuntu hat sowas
so zack next copy windows files achja das ging ja schnell so ich würde sagen während
winos installiert gehen wir mal auf ein richtiges betriebssystem in der zwischenzeit gut dass
ich 32 gigabyte ram habe oder sonst könnte ich die ganzen apps gar nicht parallel laufen
lassen so es wird mal zeit für ein richtiges betriebssystem leute damit wir uns richtig
auf winos l vorbereiten können jetzt ja das geht es mir gleich wieder besser endlich endlich
ja da habe ich drauf gewartet jetzt ist die welt wieder in ordnung das passiert eigentlich
wenn ich max fps switch suche ist google so schlau es geht max fps ist offline ok ok
alles gut so jetzt haben wir uns ein ordentliches betriebssystem angeguckt jetzt können wir
wieder stoppen und können wir uns bei der installation zugucken das geht auch schon
gleich viel schneller ich habe eh das gefühl winos ist schneller wenn man nicht hinguckt
und man wird es wahrscheinlich nie beweisen können so richtig gibt ja sogar die frage
ist der mond noch da wenn man nicht hinguckt sagen über fragen guck mal das ging jetzt
aber schnell das ging jetzt zackig das startet jetzt bestimmt und hat erstmal noch ein zehn
minuten installationsprozess das war bestimmt komplettes komplettes gbait installer wahrscheinlich
hat der installer einfach jetzt die dateien kopiert und jetzt beginnt die richtige installation
das licht noch an dem kühlschrank das ist genauso eine frage
hi im cortana wobei die gibt es nicht mehr oder ich hoffe die ist weg da drehe ich ab
wenn der cortana am start ist ich glaube ich habe gar keine soundkarte drin doch hier
soundkarte connect disconnect from house was habe ich hier ne ne ne ne wenn ich das connecte
hörte mich nicht mehr dann ist mein mikrofon weg ich muss mal kurz eine soundkarte dran
hängen gibt keine soundkarte ja sound audio audio jawoll ja hier zack sehr gut was was
machst du stopp stopp forever workstation an der stopt jetzt hängt das rein und startet
wieder dass es geht und wenn vor allem er meint es muss so sein dann sollst du es so
gut aus das ist das gegenteil von white people happy das ist was ich small windows install
als geht's wieder slim people happy ja hoffentlich geht das jetzt noch manchmal mag das window
sein wenn es gestoppt wird zwischendurch chat sagt so ein alex sagt ich kann leider nicht
upgraden cpu ist zu alt ryzen 1600 ja ich finde das auch komplett affig habe ich ja
in meinem letzten video gesagt vor allem gerade in anbetracht der tatsache dass hardware
gerade so schwer zu bekommen ist ich habe heute irgendwo gelesen dass bei einem auto
hersteller die leute jetzt wieder in kurz arbeiten müssen weil es zu wenige chips und
controller so silikonsachen halt gibt da kommt microsoft ich bin blind flash bang ist ja
gut ich muss mich mal kurz erholen sekunde sekunde ich pepega windows kam wieder ist
this the right country or region yes ich hoffe aber du lässt die sprache auf englisch mach
bloß mach bloß keine deutsche windows übersetzung da kriege ich kriege ich zustände yes richtige
country jetzt erst mal 85 privacy option auswählen ist es sag mal wie dumm wie dumm
ist windows eigentlich es fragt mich ist diese region richtig und danach ja ich möchte ganz
bestimmt united kingdom keyboard layout haben und wisst ihr was das schlimmste ist hier
drinne kannst du nicht mal sagen germany oder deutsch du musst jetzt hier durch scrollen
bis du deutsch findest in einer nicht alphabetisch sortierten liste das ist wirklich so was
von krasses 3 hat mehr 3 hat kannst du nicht sein ok ok es ist nicht deutsch und es ist
german german yes no checking for updates german ibm ne einfach nur german fragt mir
nicht was der unterschied ist wahrscheinlich irgendwelche uraltasten die es heute gar nicht
mehr gibt wie hast du keine zweite tastatur zwei keine zwei tastaturen dran ja heute mal
nicht ich habe zwei mäuse dran jetzt ernsthaft das kann man aber schlecht zeigen ich habe
nämlich eine für den zweiten bildschirm wo ich die vorschau habe also den 2 rechner
wo ich die vorschau habe und eine hier so name your pc cute chat und wenn ich kann es
skippen meinen pc zu nehmen also es gibt sachen die sollte man nicht skippen können und es
gibt sachen die sollte man skippen können also den pc zu benennen würde ich sagen sollte
man nicht skippen können aber dass man einen microsoft account braucht das sollte man skippen
können darf ich das überhaupt skippen jetzt wenn ich internetverbindung hab next ja geht
ok chat meint microsoft macht save geld durch deals mit inter und amd indem sie random
leute installation verweigern ich weiß nicht ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher was microsoft
damit verfolgt microsoft hat doch kein interesse dran microsoft hat interesse dran dass viele
leute windows verwenden und dass viele leute die neuesten windows version verwenden das ist
das eigentlich interesse von microsoft microsoft ist doch egal ob die leute jetzt cpu haben von
heute oder von von gestern und so viel wird inter und amd falls es sowas gibt microsoft
soll sicherlich auch nicht abdrücken also ich verstehe die entscheidung nicht so ganz
sie sagen es ja selbst nicht ja man vermutet nur es liegt vielleicht an irgendwelchen dm
geschichten es liegt an wie heißt es vbs ich meine nicht wischl basic ich meine wie
heißt es vsp vbs dieses neue virtualisierungs ding für passwörter und sowas ja richtig
flashbang wieder all set personal use next nein wie kann ich das skippen ok wie skippe
ich das six hat time wie geht das sign in options offline account die wollen mich wie
immer für jebaiten die wollen mich immer schön jebaiten zu microsoft account wisst
ihr was ich glaube wir müssen ja wir müssen ja gleich den den cd key recover hiervon ich
habe mich dort mit dem microsoft account angemeldet ich hoffe nicht dass mein windows cd key mit
dem microsoft account verknüpft ist der doof da gucken wir mal also was hat man jetzt hier
für option sein in sein in with security key nein ein offline account beim one account
nein ich will kein microsoft account name cute weep 93 hatten was letztes mal wir machen
wir machen in anderen namen einfach keck b fertig ist das account for a child or teenager
twitch achtung manche von euch dürfen jetzt nicht mehr weiter gucken obacht next 123
456 next 123 456 even better online account nein microsoft lasst mich in ruhe security
da habe ich da habe ich was da habe ich einen trick gelernt da habe ich einen trick gelernt
ach fuck ich kann nicht mehr zurück doch ich kann zurück ich habe einen trick gelernt wenn
man das password leer lässt wird man auch nicht nach security questions gefragt bämm
es funktioniert immer noch alter messer 5 hat time also microsoft denkt sich wenn unsicher
dann richtig unsicher war ganz einfach den für was sollten die security feature die security
fragen auch da sein wenn ich zum recover das password password ist plaud ja komplett plaud
also net max no no no no no no no haben wir es jetzt bald aber das ist wichtig nochmal
für updates zu checken weil in den zwei minuten ist ganz bestimmt ganz viel dabei gekommen
hoffentlich fängt nicht katana an ach nee sie get things ready for mich alles klar da
freue ich mich ja ich weiß sie haben jetzt so eine richtig coole fancy animation an der
stelle schon mal muss das muss man ihnen lassen das sieht schon viel moderner aus als
noch bei windows 10 ob das ob das mit blockchain technologie ist was meint ihr blockchain oder
zumindest machine learning machine learning blockchain randomizer installer die animation
ist bestimmt verkauft der sinn von nfts die zu kaufen habe ich noch nicht so genau verstanden
also da bin ich wahrscheinlich zu zu zu boomer für wenn ich mir nft kaufe das heißt ja
im prinzip ich kaufe mir die rechte stimmt ja nicht mehr ich kaufe nicht mal die rechte
ich kaufe mir irgendwas nicht näher definierbares wo ich dass ich dann sagen kann zum beispiel
mir gehört der erste tweet auf twitter aber die gehört da gar nicht er gehört nach wie
vor twitter und er ist nach wie vor auch nur über twitter abrufbar also so richtig habe
ich den sinn von nfts noch nicht verstanden plot twist niemand versteht nfts das wird
mich nicht wundern vieles was aktuell angesagt ist versteht niemand und vieles ist auch dumm
benannt also für mich ist eines der top bescheuert benahmten sachen tatsächlich serverless serverless
hört sich ja so an als geht das ohne server aber das ist schwachsinn selbstverständlich
braucht serverless noch server du brauchst keinen mehr aber serverless ist total bescheuert
benannt ok also hier sind wir am start jetzt als erstes bevor ich irgendwas mache vmw tools
installieren vmw tools installieren dass ich meinen bildschirm auflösung mal wieder hoch
machen kann ja hallo ich will vmw tools installieren hier run yes server ist bloated das ist alles
bloatet alles bildschirme sind auch bloatet man kann auch einfach drucker verwenden so
nadeldrucker bildschirme bloatet maus bloatet gehäuse bloatet cpu lüfter bloatet ssd bloat
und smartphone bloatet zu aller zeiten nee nee alles bloat deinstallier tiktok please
wieso ist da standardmäßig tiktok drauf nö ein tiktok drauf oder hopp yes restart
das wars das war drauf aber die windows suche findet es nicht das ist der klassiker wieder
oder ja gucken wir gleich windows suche keck weh ja so wenn jetzt alles funktioniert soll
ich einen fullscreen bekomme ja das sieht doch schon gleich viel besser aus welche gpu benutzt
du ich habe eine 1080 ti aber das hier ist in der vm die was ist das eigentlich für
von monka es musik hier das ist doch nicht immer jetzt mal ernsthaft ist das hier in
irgendeiner art und weise ist das in irgendeiner art und weise relaxing calm calming das ist
eher anstrengend mach lieber haftbefehl ja willst dass ich gebannt werde so wo ist tiktok
ich sehe tiktok tatsächlich
nix wie weg ist das jetzt den hier ernst ist das ist das den hier ernst da bleibt so
ein komisches so ein fleck warum ist das so ein fleck was das für ein scheiß ist das
so ein fleck clip jam ist der dienst von max a verrat auch nicht alles clip jam das hatte
schon mal einen guten namen ach das ist noch nicht mal installiert der installiert es jetzt
erst nach das ist ja doppelt gebate guck mal das sieht aus als wäre es installiert
ist es aber gar nicht einfach mega jebait ja erstmal sein in natürlich im prinzip ist
das hier nix anderes wie ein browser mit einem eigenen gefärbten fenster so ein schwachsinn
das braucht doch echt niemand weg clip jam an install spotify wenn wenn ich da drauf
klicke hier kann es angeblich an installen wenn wenn ich da drauf klicke ach guck mal
jetzt bleibt nur noch so einer dann installiert das ey was ein schwachsinn an installen weg
oh jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich gebrickt ich habe es kaputt gemacht ich habe es installiert
und an installen gleichzeitig windows please warum sind dann solche simpelste sachen kann
man noten an installen und man kann ernsthaft was das kostet ja ist eine gute frage kriege
ich das hier auf anpinn zack guck mal leute ich habe es geschafft der komische pleck ist
nicht mehr da alle wichtig solitär ist am start da freuen sich die ganzen leute die
microsoft soll ich mein alter lass mich doch einfach darf ich ich habe keine ahnung wie
solitär funktioniert beide weh ich bin glaube ich der einzig der nie solitär gespielt hat
exzellent huge win so ist not bett wenigstens schon installiert ja ich hoffe mal ja anscheinend
aber da hat sich nichts getan not bett sieht noch genauso not bett hat jetzt runde menüecken
immerhin und es ist not bett version 10.2 102.13.0 wahnsinn so was ist das für eine interne
als erstes müssen wir das redesigned paint noch mal kurz angucken was warum ist das paint
nicht redesigned hä das haben die doch groß angekündigt muss man das updaten oder so
ach store updaten vielleicht das ist so broken af dass es jetzt verschiedene update dinger
gibt wo sind die überhaupt wo sind hier überhaupt updates ja ach du schau ach du scheiße da
muss ja da muss ja alles neu sondern wo sehe ich jetzt was updated das ist auch der alte
store ja ja updated das jetzt der sucht erstmal ja offensichtlich und der macht und der macht
nebenbei macht da windows defender update ok nice sehr gut die windows web experience
oder die hatten schönes icon anklicken während anklicken während dem installieren ist kein
gutes idee keine gute idee gewesen glaube ich jetzt acht meine güte der update das ganze
system noch mal ok die web das web experience pack microsoft people das ist das was hier
unten war unter windows 10 was kein mensch verwendet hat microsoft people das ist teams
das ist teams was jetzt integriert ist gibt es eigentlich noch skype verwendet microsoft
selbst den mist noch nähe oder das ist schon mal gar nicht mehr mit dabei ja zum glück
skype war eine zeit lang mega beliebt also quasi so zu 2011 12 13 und dann hat microsoft
gesagt sie machen so eine komische uvp app drauf draus ja und mit der zeit kam auch discord
und alles aber seit es so eine komische uvp app geworden ist wollte das niemand mehr verwenden
jetzt wsl ja standardmäßig bestimmt nicht das muss man bestimmt installieren wir gleich
installieren wir gleich mal gucken wie das jetzt funktioniert war auch einfach nur scheiße
dann ja ich habe ich habe skype nie wieder benutzt winget chat was meint ihr ist winget
installiert oder nicht predictions versage starten ist winget drauf da könnt ihr eure
kanalpunkte mal auf was sinnvolles wetten ja nein so was meint ihr ist winget drauf
also ich würde sagen die überwiegende die überwiegende teil der leute mein das ist
nicht drauf install valorant nehmen warum ich bin mir wirklich nicht sicher ob es drauf
ist ich mein microsoft hat das so groß angepriesen also dann schauen wir mal ob winget drauf
ist ihr habt eindeutig zu viel kanalpunkte gibt es den internet explorer noch das gucken
wir gleich mal nein anscheinend nicht aber es gibt internet explorer settings also es
gibt internet explorer settings aber es gibt kein internet explorer mehr muss man das nicht
verstehen oder also schauen wir mal ist winget drauf also hier schon mal nicht wir gucken
ein power shell kann er sache ja nie trauen winget nein winget ist nicht drauf was explore
punkt exe nein gibt es nicht mehr also es ist zumindest winget ist nicht
nicht hier irgendwie finden war und der normalen suche auch nicht was ich kann es im store
suchen ne wo kämen wir denn dahin wo kämen wir denn dahin wenn der store irgendwas sinnvolles
am start hätte oh was war das der microsoft store hat sich
rebootet gerade ah jetzt sieht es auch nach neuem store aus
jetzt haben wir den neuen store ok da ist das neue paint jawoll endlich ich wart schon die
ganze zeit drauf endlich das neue paint jetzt hat es die installation ja schon gelähmt teste
mal im terminal du meinst dem neuen hier meinst hier das ist ja nicht terminal wenigstens
haben sie neue terminal app drauf winget was winget ist doch da ja was denn du ja was jetzt
ist es jetzt da oder nicht im alten ist es nicht da im neuen ist es da es ist doch da
ok nice poggers so dann marque dann mag ich mal kurz die prediction prediction vorhersage
verwalten ist winget drauf ergebnis wählen ist winget drauf ja winget ist drauf rip points
easy easy finde ich interessant dass es nur darüber geht
ach meint ihr das ist mit den updates gekommen ja gut das würde ich aber auch noch auch
noch zählen tatsächlich ist mit den updates gekommen standardmäßig ist es wahrscheinlich
im iso nicht drin aber sobald du updates machst es das zählt das zählt das zählt für ist
dabei also das lasse ich gelten so also das dazu ok nice aber zumindest wenigstens mal
eine sinnvolle sache update sag mal wie lang update das eigentlich was neu wahlen oder
was chat wir wählen jetzt einfach so so lange neu bis das rauskommt was wir haben wollen
moin hast du schon die world gespielt ja die beta aber nicht die release version ich werde
die release version nicht anfangen jetzt wird es die musik aber wissen store wie wärs
mit update
also es ist immer noch unglaublich wie schlecht eins kann man jetzt auch auf winget beziehen
wie schlecht die das gebaut haben im vergleich wenn man mal guckt wie linux package manager
schon oder meinetwegen auch wie heißt das ding wie heißt dieser community package manager
für mac os bruh genau wie gut der kram funktioniert versus das was microsoft hier veranstaltet
hat ich meine die update über den store sagt und winget hat auch richtig viele probleme
also ok das hat das hat kein bock das möchte schon mal nicht updaten hier das store sagt
nee gibt es nicht keine updates das mag einfach nicht na gut wenn das store nicht macht da
gucken wir sonst mal nach darf ich jetzt darf ich eigentlich settings machen ich glaube
ich darf keine settings einstellungen machen weil ich kein windows key das ist immer noch
da ich fasse es nicht ich habe gestern ich habe gestern hier gesessen ja und gehofft
das ist nur in meiner preview version drin aber das ist immer noch drin guckt mal der
größte schwachsinn aller zeiten warum ist das da was ist die daseinsberechtigung davon
pass mal auf wenn ihr jetzt in ihr so ein ordner geht ihr könnt jetzt rechts klicken
da könnt ihr so sachen machen wie icons groß sortieren blabla und dann gibt es hier unten
noch einen knopf show more options und das ist das alte menü so ein schwachsinn hoch
10 also wenn man diese option braucht also wenn man diese optik ist so eng geblieben
wenn man diese option doch braucht mal ernsthaft mal ernsthaft microsoft mal ernsthaft wenn
man diese option braucht hätte man da nicht auf die idee kommen können dass dann irgendwas
nicht stimmt also irgendwas scheint mit dem neuen nicht so ganz zu passen wenn man das
alte immer noch braucht und umgedreht vielleicht hätte man das alte einfach weiter ausbauen
sollen anstatt das neue zu bauen ein so was unsinniges so was schwachsinniges das regt
mich immer auf so so gefuddelt hier bis abel schau mal ob ich will es ja nicht disabel
vielleicht will ich ja tatsächlich more options haben das neue ist einfach ein sucker menü
ja ich weiß das ist für alte apps die sich hier reinklicken und so aber das will ich
ja vielleicht haben das will ich ja vielleicht haben die sollen einfach das neue weglassen
und das alte ausbauen dass es weiter funktioniert ich meine du kannst doch nicht einfach nur
weil du keinen bock hast an der alten sache weiter zu programmieren zu sagen wir machen
das weg und als untermenü das ist das ist nicht das was man als software anbieter machen
sollte das ist sehr halbherzig ja ok gut das ist jetzt übrigens die die die ähm eigentlichen
fenster die dann aufgehen aufgehen sehen halt immer noch so aus als passen sie null in das
neue designe guckt euch hier mal das neue designe und guckt euch an den kram windows
ist halt so ein gestücke gestücke laufen mittlerweile übrigens um euch jetzt mal zu erfreuen das
control panel ist natürlich auch noch da wer hätte auch was anderes gedacht selbstverständlich
ist das control panel noch da so display settings zack personalize das geht jetzt nicht weil
ich nicht registriert habe ne themes ja ja das geht jetzt nicht weil ich nicht aktiviert
habe aber hält sich hält sich in grenzen gibt es irgendeinen coolen hack das zu aktivieren
ohne zu ohne windows zu aktivieren kann man vielleicht dark mode so einschalten turn on
dark mode for apps poggers nope geht nicht nicht schlimm nicht schlimm das haben wir
uns ja in der anderen vm schon oft genug angeguckt wie dark mode aussieht so also dann schauen
wir mal ein paar sachen an ist pinball dabei gibt es nicht kein pinball am start aber solitaire
ist am start ob ich das hier jemals verwende ach guck mal wenn man die search weg macht
kommt man nicht mal zurück zu diesem menü das ist irgendwie so wie lockt man sich eigentlich
jetzt aus wie lock ich mich aus ernsthaft ok da kann man sich dran gewöhnen da kann
man sich das ist ok da kann man sich dran gewöhnen in windows fotos ist jetzt ein video editor
drinne wirklich foto das ist fotos nein ich will mich nicht für ihren scheiß sein innen
albums people ich werde es nie verwenden ich werde es einfach niemals benutzen ich weiß
gar nicht wie ich diesen kram überhaupt bedienen soll ok wo gibt es wo gibt es irgendwie beispiel
pictures ich brauche mal ein beispielbild auf wir laden uns jetzt mal irgendwas runter
edge ist gut geh auf geh auf please einfach starten complete setup ja perfekt nein ich
will einfach den browser verwenden google please geh weg ich kriege anfälle ok ja ja
wir brauchen den testbild alles da perfekt das da das brauchen wir save image downloads
alles gut so jetzt können wir das aus prob downloads ach import items muss ich das jetzt
track und droppen sind immer leute ich weiß gar nicht ich bin ich bin nicht in der lage
den kram zu benutzen import downloads import item png ist too much das kriegts nicht hin
selected ok was habe ich da jetzt von ist ja schön wenn das in meiner collection ist
und weiter und weiter also was nee jetzt ist das album weg ich weiß nicht was ich damit
machen soll ernsthaft ich habe keine ahnung ach nee es ist immer noch da create oh huge
animation save in one try wie wäre es mit save auf der festplatte slideshow unglaubliches
feature ads share kann ich das nicht einfach was auch immer watch gibt es den knopf nicht
edit unten rechts was des massive editor hier effekte effekte motion zoom in jawoll
ja oh zoom in pan right alles zusammen zoom in left dann ein wahres wunder wunderwerk
background music happy beat jawoll unglaublich ja happy beat cat jam happy beat will ich haben
dann das war aber ein sehr kurzer happy beat jetzt wer gibt es nicht ok noch nächstes
nächstes bild nächstes bild was auch immer motion ok das zoomt jetzt till ab gut wunderbar
haben jetzt eingebaut wie kann man das jetzt finish video export session session export
get me a poggers poggers video das brauche ich jetzt export video file da ist es meisterwerk
absolutes meisterwerk compare photos together interessant was wir was wollen die mir sagen
damit ich hasse dass ich krieg anfälle wenn zeug laufen irgendwo aufpoppt und ich nicht
weiß wozu es gehört was hat das video für eine auflösung hat es jetzt 1000 1080p ja
open mit an der media player ist immer noch am start ja da bin ich aber beruhigt dass
der media player noch da ist customize setting ich würde sagen das schreit nach endlos schleife
einfach einfach dass das beste video was man mit was man machen kann und der sound das
fängt an und ist instant fertig neues kanal intro sehr gut also das allerwichtigste feature
haben wir jetzt anscheinend schon mal ausprobiert das brauche ich total oft meint ihr jetzt
chat mal die frage an euch meint ihr es gibt wirklich leute die das die das regelmäßig
verwenden um damit irgendwie ihre all ihre foto album zu auf zu hübschen um sie dann
anderen leuten zu sagen ja meint ihr das wirklich ernsthaft ich kann mir das nicht
vorstellen dass das leute verwenden die bedienung sagt und was was was will man damit dann wenn
es fertig ist ja ihr habt wahrscheinlich habt ihr recht wahrscheinlich gibt es wirklich
leute das fein ich finde es einfach nur unsinnig gut haben jetzt ausprobiert super super mega
krasses feature so für mich ich muss jetzt ich muss jetzt mal kurz chrome installieren
chrome install them aber please nicht die deutsche version die englischsprachige version
ja ja nein ich will chrome nicht besser machen google hat schon genug kohle so chrome setup
erstmal und jetzt und jetzt will ich mal was ausprobieren ob man immer noch nicht die
gruppierung ausschalten kann schau mal bitte nach ob md ne das schaue ich nicht da weil
ich nicht weiß was das macht das ist wenn das ist windows batch magic keine ahnung was
es macht oder was es machen soll ok chrome ist am start excellent da ist es ok chrome
öffnen sagt nächstes fenster nächstes fenster nächstes fenster ok wir haben jetzt
vier chrome fenster so und wie macht man das mit der gruppierung aus geht wahrscheinlich
wirklich nicht wenn dann schon über win get installiert oh ja sekunde sekunde das müssen
wir jetzt machen moment mal ihr habt ihr habt nichts gesehen remove remove ich habe chrome
nicht installiert gba das hat nicht habt ihr nicht gesehen chrome uninstall jawoll ok das
sieht jetzt ein bisschen einheitlicher aus wie vorher ist das ist der alte installer immer
noch drauf ne ist er weg mal control panel gucken er ist immer noch da das hätte mich
jetzt ja auch gewundert wenn der wenn der weg gewesen wäre das hätte mich ganz ganz
stark gewundert ok chrome so also habt ihr nicht gesehen wir gucken jetzt nach wir machen
das jetzt wieso der richtige richtige kack bob der windows das ist ja wirklich wirklich
die bettke musik extrem viel besser so also wir installieren jetzt chrome aus dem store
aber was natürlich nicht geht und was voller fake chrome ist
das ist das ist so das ist so mega pains gem ja komm wir geben mal neun euro aus was
kriegen wir dann hier neun euro jahr das app ist die user guide vor google chrome jawoll
von rainbow studios richtig weltbekannte weltbekannte hersteller stimmt auch hier großes in die
studio wie blitz hat so alles klar das hat jetzt ok jetzt firefox haben wir nicht erzählt
man kann jetzt auch unpackaged apps rein machen advanced guide flash browser what the fuck
was bin ich was bin ich hier sehen es wird ja wird ja es wird ja noch schlimmer ja klar
der kommostrom x browser was browser uwp internet browser meine güte wie viel kacke
es hier in diesem store gibt ok also da drüber kann man schon mal nix installieren dann muss
jetzt dann dann muss jetzt wird da muss jetzt win get dran meinst du kombine taskbar buttons
unter taskbar settings ja ich glaube schon dass ich das meine aber erstmal muss ich
ein browser installiert bekommen das ist nicht so einfach wie das aussieht ok terminal
muss auf jeden fall hier unten dran hello track und drop geht schon mal nicht ich bin begeistert
in to taskbar alles klar ok win get install chrome ich glaube es ist nicht chrome ich
glaube es ist google.chrome oder sowas aber install chrome geht wahrscheinlich auch was
sources source ich kreier alles ich microsoft kein problem ok der chromosome browser was
für ein ding also genau es ist nicht chrome es ist google google.chrome will ich installieren
wie kann man eine kommando zeilen bedienung so verkacken ist es minus minus id ja genau
so stelle ich mir das vor wenn ich in insta wenn ich package manager habe genauso dass
ich das im prinzip der package manager den installer starte den ich dann durchklicken
muss sehr gut sehr gut aber das kenne ich schon das kenne ich schon das haben wir uns
ja schon mal angeguckt im stream das ist aber hey da mache ich microsoft gar keinen allzu
großen vorwurf für es ist einfach so es haben sich es haben sich über 40 jahre oder wie
lange es jetzt windows gibt hat sich so ein krasser wild wuchs angesammelt gibt es mal
wenn ihr auf firefox ja gibt es es hat sich so ein krasser wildwuchs angesammelt bei installern
das können die gar nicht unter einen hut bringen passt mal auf jetzt gucken wir mal
ob das removing funktioniert uninstall minus id google chrome ich hoffe mal bei chrome funktioniert
bei chrome ist relativ simpel und kannst ja auch über kommando zeilen so installieren
root rechte für was auch immer ok das funktioniert wenigstens weil es gibt genug dinger da backt
die ander backt die uninstall warum ich da unbedingt admin rechte für brauche ist mir
jetzt persönlich nicht wirklich klar warum warum jetzt mehr als warum brauche ich admin
rechte und chrome zu installieren hätte microsoft vor 20 jahren mal ein ordentliches installer
framework gemacht die hätten vor 20 jahren schon package manager machen sollen das funkt
funktioniert auch ohne admin rechte moment ich an install noch mal soll ich einfach mal
nein machen bei der installation ob man ob chatterino drin war einfach mal nein no nee
nee von wegen von wegen das funktioniert jebaited chat das funktioniert nicht man brauche
admin rechte ganz ganz wichtig für den browser gibt admin rechte jawohl ok jetzt haben wir
chrome ausprobiert minus minus user gibt es das moment dass das das interessiert mich
jetzt tatsächlich ob es das gibt wegen dem updater service naja da wird es wahrscheinlich
sein hast du recht aber warum nicht einfach fragen außerdem warum braucht man für updater
service eigentlich root rechte ich mein klar um ein service zu installieren aber man könnte
doch einfach wenn man das programm starten update check machen wenn du das terminal
als admin start ist ja dann brauche ich keine admin rechte dann habe ich die admin rechte
ja schon also da brauche ich keine super zusätzliche admin rechte egal wir lassen es jetzt so also
chrome starten chrome best match tak da ist es sehr das default huge anpinnen anpinnen
please so äh mehr fenster mehr fenster so und jetzt ist die frage kann man irgendwie
einstellen dass die taskleiste diese fenster nicht mehr gruppiert ich habe eine persönliche
eine riesen abneigung dagegen früher ging das relativ einfach du bist hier in die settings
gegangen und hast gesagt nicht mehr nicht mehr gruppieren aber das gibt es jetzt nicht
mehr da gibt es bestimmt irgendwelche registry hacks ok windows 11 group taskbar sieben plus
taskbar tweaker was für ein ding was ist sieben plus taskbar tweaker aber vor computer bild
ja da lade ich mir auch immer sachen runter deren ernst ja das ist denen ernst so eines
der wichtigsten funktionen wenn man halbwegs übersicht haben will ist einfach weg ganz
ehrlich ich blicke hier nicht durch ich blicke hier nicht durch ich weiß dass es höchst
umstritten ich habe letztens im chat gefragt ich weiß nicht wir können ja heute auch
noch mal im chat fragen was sagt ihr was sagt ihr gruppieren oder so wie ich es hier habe
also ich habe ja so dass es quasi immer pro ein eigenes tab aufgeht oder ein eigenes programm
oder also was ist lieber so in der taskleiste oder so niemals grusel das ist also anscheinend
sehr umstritten hat jeder so sein deswegen ist auch das wichtige dass die option da
ist weil ich bin der meinung microsoft sollte einem hier keinen wie soll ich keine keine
bedienen keine vorgabe machen also nicht nicht nicht so ihre sache den leuten aufzwingen
einfach sagen hey stellt so ein wie ihr wollt so also die musik die passt ja richtig gut
ok gibt es irgendwelche register der 7 plus taskbar tweaker erleichtert die bedienung
der tasse geht das ok wir laden jetzt wir leiten 7 plus taskbar tweaker runter ja ich
akzeptiere alle cookies kein problem reizt die taskleiste aus
er geht das überhaupt unter wien aus elf wir müssen also wenn aus elf was sagen jetzt
hau zu an krupp eikens der nörd der nörd schalke was ist eigengruppen ist klar du
ninetea
Nein, das führe ich bestimmt nicht aus.
Mit die App.
Gehst du mir weg?
Alter, das ist doch krass, so ernst.
Okay, das geht, das muss doch gehen.
Das muss doch irgendwie gehen.
That sucks.
Ja, aber richtig.
Suckt es.
So, wir machen jetzt einfach mal...
Google, richtig nice.
Hier.
Google Hack.
Einfach auf letzte Woche stellen.
Auto-Change-Size, Group What's New.
Nee, das interessiert keinen.
Oh, was ist denn Schwachsinn?
Was ein Blödsinn, Alter.
Warum geht das nicht?
Das hier funktioniert doch bestimmt nicht unter Windows.
Das hier funktioniert doch bestimmt nicht unter Windows 11, oder?
First Look Windows.
Tatsächlich?
Doch, das scheint zu funktionieren unter Windows 11.
Der Ram Michael.
Wir probieren jetzt mal dieses komische Tool einfach aus.
Download.
Oh nee, ist das jetzt der Chip Installer?
Nein, das ist der Chip Installer.
Alter, du wirst heutzutage wirklich...
Du wirst an jeder Ecke, wirst du chibated,
irgendeinen Müll zu installieren, den du nicht haben willst.
Wie kriege ich das jetzt so runtergeladen?
Erstmal löschen den Chip Installer.
Komm, es geht los.
Wo ist der Download?
Manuelle Installation.
Sehr gut.
Oh, Avira hat das geprüft.
Oh ja, da bin ich natürlich gleich beruhigt.
Bitte hier.
Hör auf mit mir zu reden.
Ja, bumm.
Ja, aber das passt schon.
Run anyway.
Okay.
Jawoll.
Startup vielleicht erstmal nicht.
Okay, wir haben keine Schall...
Wir haben keine Schall...
Wir haben keine Möglichkeit, diese Scheiße aktuell auszuschalten.
Remove.
Dann lösche ich es halt wieder.
Der Ram Michael.
Also Chat, wenn ihr irgendeine glorreiche Idee habt,
wie ich der Taskleiste wieder beibringen kann,
dass meine Symbole nicht gruppiert sind,
dann nur her damit.
Nur her damit.
Also es scheitert schon an einfachen Sachen.
61% finden kopieren geil.
Dann sieht man mal, dass es sehr sinnvoll ist,
eine Option einzubauen.
Gut, das funktioniert auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht.
Das ist schon mal nicht so nice.
Aber, aber, das Wichtigste ist,
wir haben jetzt ein neues Paint.
Wir haben jetzt ein neues Paint.
Also, damit sollten ja eigentlich jegliche Fragen...
Moment, ist das der Colourpick-Dialog von Windows 95?
Sekunde.
Das ist der Colourpicker von Windows 95.
Okay, okay, er hat jetzt runde Ecken.
Er hat jetzt runde Ecken.
Solide.
Ja gut.
Hey, warum was austauschen, was funktioniert?
Man kann ihn nicht vorwerfen, es gibt keine Innovation.
Ich meine, die Ecken sind rund.
Wobei, man sagt, es gibt keine Innovation.
Aber es gibt keine Innovation.
Ich meine, die Ecken sind rund, wobei man sagen muss,
dafür kann der Colourpicker nichts.
Die runden Ecken sind einfach für alle Anwendungen da.
Sehr schön.
Huge Colourpicker.
Das haben wir gebraucht.
So, es gibt ein neues Feature in Paint.
Ganz massive Feature, das einzig neue Paint-Feature.
Man kann jetzt Marker machen.
Guck hier, man kann markern.
Ein neues Paint-Feature.
Also ich kann jetzt quasi das hier einfügen.
Das hier einfügen.
Und dann kann ich sagen, Marker.
Und dann kann ich hier marken und dann kann ich sagen,
ach hier, guckt chat hier oben, da hier, guckt her.
Das meine ich hier, das meine ich, wenn ich es nicht verstanden habe.
Nee, das ging, das Brushes ist neu.
Das gab es vorher nicht.
Oder?
Nee, das gab es vorher nicht.
Ach, das sieht jetzt plus anders aus.
Ernsthaft?
Das haben die einfach nur...
Na, das sieht schon hässlich aus.
Bisschen laut vielleicht?
Ok, was genau kann da ein Paint-Neues?
Es hat ein paar mehr Marker.
Doch Oilbrush und sowas, das gab es hier noch nicht beim alten.
Also außer, dass die jetzt so eine komische Ribbon Bar gemacht haben,
ist doch nichts Neues.
Jetzt mal, passt mal, also jetzt mal, jetzt mal ernsthaft, Microsoft.
Guckt mal, wie sich der Windows-Typ überschlagen hat auf Twitter
über das Beautiful Redesigned Paint.
Wie heißt der Typ?
Pasos oder so?
Twitter Redesigned Paint.
Alter, ich habe vergessen, wie der Typ heißt.
Windows-Chef, wie heißt der Typ von Microsoft jetzt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Irgendetwas von P.
Wie heißt er denn?
Twitter.
Anoy?
Kann das sein?
Ja!
Anos, den meine ich, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das ist er.
Okay.
Redesigned.
Ist er das?
Ja, den Dude meine ich.
Der, der immer so guckt, als weint da gleich.
So.
Paint.
Der hat einen Post zu Paint gemacht.
Hier.
Was die da für einen Aufriss gemacht haben.
Windows 11 First Look.
This is the Beautifully Redesigned Paint App.
Coming soon to Windows.
Can't wait to see your reactions.
Also, jetzt mal ernsthaft, es ist nichts neu an Paint.
Das Einzige, was neu ist, ist so eine fucking Ribbon Bar.
Ist das wirklich alles?
Okay, muss ich mir das Video nochmal dazu angucken.
Was ist das für eine Musik?
Dazu.
Ernsthaft?
Okay.
Ich mach mal den Sound aus.
What's this?
Was ist das?
Das ist doch genau der alte Kram.
Das ist genau der alte Kram.
Plus ein Ribbon Bar jetzt.
Also, das wäre mir den, ganz ehrlich, das wäre mir den Post nicht wert gewesen.
Und mal ernsthaft, so was überhaupt.
Das hier.
Das macht euch, wenn ihr den Sound auskommt,
hat ihr schon einen Hobbyentwickler in zwei Tagen seine Ribbon Bar.
Anstatt das andere, was vorher da war.
Naja, es ist Microsoft.
Was wollen wir?
Großartig.
Ach, Stiftarten gab's vorher nicht?
Echt nicht?
Nice.
Huge.
Immerhin.
Was gab's vorher nicht?
Stiftarten.
Wo hier?
Das da.
Nee.
Wo sind Stiftarten?
Schieß los.
Wo ist hier was?
Was muss ich gucken?
Was muss ich klicken, was es vorher nicht gab?
Übrigens, die Icons sind auch immer noch die Windows 3.11 Icons oder was?
Brush?
Na, Brushes gab's vorher auch.
Haben wir doch eben grad schon gesehen, dass es das gab.
Brushes.
Brushes gab's vorher auch schon hier.
Brushes gab's vorher auch schon.
Guck hier, Marker.
Brush.
Aber nicht alle.
Guck mal hier.
Oilbrot?
Na doch.
Den gibt's auch.
Also mehr oder weniger.
Okay, es gibt vielleicht zwei Brushes mehr oder so.
Ey, das sieht immer noch aus hier unter Windows 3.1.
3.11.
Okay.
Also in der Richtung hat's schon mal nichts getan.
Gut, Next.
Also was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Bei Windows 10 geht das Ungrouping im Rack-Edit.
Ja, leider geht das unter Windows 11 wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Hier.
Aber das geht wahrscheinlich unter Windows 11 nicht.
Nee, was muss man einstellen, was?
Was muss man einstellen, was?
Abschließend neu starten.
Keine Chance, wir kriegen's nicht weg.
Nope, gibt's nicht.
Warum gängeln die einen immer so?
Übrigens, habt ihr schon das beste, mega poggers neue Feature gesehen?
Kannst du mal das neue Notepad zeigen?
Da ist nichts neu.
Notepad ist noch der gleiche alte Krämpel wie vorher auch schon.
Hat sich nix geändert.
Außer wenn du runde Ecken als neues Feature siehst.
Wobei die runden Ecken ja nicht von Notepad kommen,
sondern Windows malt halt die Ecken anders.
Also das Notepad ist im Prinzip genau der gleiche Krämpel wie vorher auch.
Auch wenn es eine neue Versionsnummer hat.
Passt mal auf, super krasses poggers Feature.
Guckt mal, wenn ihr das jetzt rechts anklickt,
könnt ihr hier oben sagen, Cut, Cut, Copy.
Warum hat das so einen riesen Delay?
Delete.
Das konntet ihr vorher auch schon über diese Leiste.
Aber hier könnte man argumentieren, das ist eventuell ein bisschen schöner.
Was ich halt immer noch affig finde, ist, dass es das alte Menü noch braucht.
WSL.
Wir haben doch so oft WSL installiert, da wird doch kein Unterschied.
Ich adde das mal.
Öffne mal Control-Exe und gib oben in der Leiste C-Doppelpunkt ein.
Was soll ich öffnen?
Control-Exe?
Du meinst das hier?
Und dann gib mal oben was, C-Doppelpunkt ein.
Wait a minute.
Ich hab jetzt nur den alten und den neuen Explorer.
Easy.
Da muss ich sagen, ich fand das super.
Da muss ich sagen, ich fand den Explorer immer noch nie hübsch.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist mir der alte sogar lieber als der neue.
Kannst du mal 7-zip installieren, ob das beim rechte Klick direkt...
Nein, Witz nicht.
Da könnte ich mit dir wetten, dass es das nicht wird.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das hier Plug-in-able ist, falls es so ein Wort gibt.
Jetzt mal rechte Klick im alten.
Ja, im alten gibt es den gleich wieder den richtigen rechts Klick.
Also ich frage mich, ob man das hier Plug-in-en kann.
Mein Open Terminal geht ja an so, ob es hier für Plug-ins gibt, dass man das machen kann.
7-zip können wir ruhig mal ausprobieren.
Ich finde leider den richtigen Browser nicht.
7-zip.
Moment, wir machen Package Manager.
WinGet install 7-zip.
Kann man die Abstände zwischen den Zeilen im Explorer auch auf nicht episch breit einstellen.
Was hier meinste?
Tja.
Ne.
Anscheinend nicht.
Das braucht man nicht.
Das braucht man 2021 nicht.
Das ist ein Feature.
Du dachtest immer nur, dass du das brauchst, aber du brauchst das gar nicht.
Doch, Explorer Einstellung.
Okay.
Pass auf.
Hackermans.
Wie geht das?
Wie kriegen das heraus?
Properties?
Ne.
Moment, die Musik ist mir gerade ein bisschen zu hektisch.
So, wo könnte das sein?
Options?
Ah, altes Fenster.
Okay, Options.
View?
Search?
Ne.
General.
Und jetzt?
View?
Und dann?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Always show icons.
Decrease space.
Eieieiei.
Es geht.
Also, ich muss ja sagen, das ist super, also intuitiv platziert.
Da hätte ich ja, da hätte ich sofort danach gesucht.
Aber ich bin begeistert, dass ihr das wisst.
Also, ist es nice, dass es da für ne Option gibt.
Aber wenn es für so einen kleinen Scheiß ne Option gibt, warum gibt es keine Option, die Taskbar zu entgruppieren?
So, 7zip installieren.
Also.
7zip.
Minus, minus ID.
Warum brauch ich für jeden Kack Routerechte?
Na gut, in dem Fall verstehe ich's ja sogar.
So.
Hier sollte jetzt, hier sollte jetzt 7zip und sowas drinne sein.
Sagen wir uns einfach mal hier, keine Ahnung, entpacken oder so.
Hier, hier ist 7zip.
Keine Ahnung, entpacken oder so.
Hier, hier ist 7zip drinne.
Im Menü.
Und hier ist 7zip natürlich nicht drinne.
Guck mal, wenn man jetzt, wenn man jetzt was entpacken will.
Wenn man jetzt was entpacken will mit 7zip, musst du immer auf show more options gehen.
Und sagen 7zip open archive.
Das ist so hängen geblieben.
Das ist so dumm einfach.
Das tut weh, das zu sehen.
Warum macht man es den Leuten denn so schwer?
Na gut.
Microsoft will das die Leute nur das Terminal fällen.
Ja, das wird es ganz bestimmt sein.
Gut, also das funktioniert so schon mal nicht.
So, was können wir denn jetzt, Chat, was probieren wir, was können wir denn sonst so Neues ausbringen?
Ach, ich weiß es, ich weiß es, ich weiß es.
Wie sieht es denn aus mit Computermanagement?
Das ist bestimmt immer noch das gleiche von Windows Vista, oder?
Ja.
Device Manager, ja, das ist immer noch Windows Vista.
Was du verpasst hast, ganz viel, ganz viel Pains Champ von Microsoft.
Richtig viel Pains Champ.
Wenn du Edge nicht verwenden willst, warum benutzt du dann Chrome?
Weil Chrome Chrome ist.
Oder wie, hä?
Chrome ist das Original.
Warum soll ich irgendeinen Fork verwenden oder irgendeinen Fake Chrome, wenn ich Chrome verwenden kann?
Da sehe ich den Sinn nicht drin.
Ich benutze Firefox, Chrome.
Gut, manchmal noch Chromium.
Ich hatte eine Zeit lang auch noch Vivaldi dabei installiert.
Ach so.
Warum sollte ich Bing verwenden?
Ich kriege schon Anfälle, wenn ich Bing aufmache und das Ding mich nach irgendeinem komischen Setup durchklicken will.
Ich will einfach einen Browser aufmachen.
Geht WSLG?
Das können wir in der VM nicht richtig ausprobieren.
Gibt es einen Dark Mode?
Ja, es gibt einen Dark Mode.
Der ist auch tatsächlich ganz okay.
Ich kann es bloß nicht anschalten, weil ich keine Lizenz aktiviert habe.
Ich habe noch eine andere VM mit einer neueren Testversion.
Da geht das.
Der Dark Mode ist tatsächlich ganz ganz in Ordnung.
Gibt es Opera GX?
Bestimmt.
So, ach hier übrigens auch super super massive neues Feature.
Guck mal.
Man kann jetzt Fenster anders anordnen.
Hab das gesehen.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Ach ja, und es gibt tatsächlich ein ganz cooles neues Feature.
Schaut mal.
Man kann jetzt mehrere Desktops anlegen.
Das ging ja vorher auch schon.
Aber man kann jetzt den Hintergrund ändern.
Man könnte den Hintergrund ändern von den unterschiedlichen Desktops.
Hätte man das registriert.
Also, man kann jetzt unterschiedliche Hintergründe pro Desktop haben.
Und irgendwie, irgendwo, ich weiß nicht wie,
kann man sich jetzt auch diese Sessions hier speichern,
dass er die automatisch wieder herstellt.
Habe ich aber keine Ahnung, wie das ist.
Übrigens, diese Leiste hier neben, die gibt es immer noch.
Die sieht jetzt ein bisschen anders aus, aber die verwendet immer noch kein Mensch.
Guck mal, Badgetime zeigt sogar hier schon an.
Mal Timezone einstellen.
Berlin.
Wo sind wir hier?
Wir sind nicht UTC plus eins, oder?
Sind wir nicht UTC, sind wir nicht, sind wir nicht CEST?
UTC plus zwei gerade?
Was auch immer.
Ja, gut.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich, wird noch mal extra berechnet.
Und nicht in diesem Dropdown.
Gibt es noch irgendwas, was ich ausprobieren soll, Leute?
Mir fällt gerade nichts ein.
Außer, dass es Hardpains champt.
Also, ich glaube, das ist das, was ich jetzt ausprobieren soll.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich jetzt ausprobieren soll.
Mir fällt gerade nichts ein, außer, dass es Hardpains champt.
Wozu ich nur sagen kann, Microsoft.
Nee, WSL mit GUI probiere ich heute nicht aus.
WSL mit GUI kann ich nicht ausprobieren.
GUI unter der VM funkt.
Das habe ich schon ausprobiert im Vorfeld.
GUI unter der VM geht nicht wirklich gut.
Also, das neue GUI.
Und WSL installieren haben wir schon so oft gemacht.
Und das ist auch sehr unspektakulär.
Windows 11 größer Linux kommt auf alles, was du machen willst.
Wie bei allem.
Kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Hast du schon versucht, den Standard-Browser zu ändern?
Ja, habe ich gemacht.
Das funktioniert.
Ich weiß aber hier nicht mehr, wo man das macht.
Irgendwo.
Apps und Features.
Wo ändere ich die Default-Programme?
Mal gucken, ob ich die finde.
Default.
Default-Apps, da ist es doch.
Nee, das ist was anderes.
Browser?
Dann weiß ich nicht, wo ich die Default-Apps ändere.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht hier.
Aber ist das hier richtig?
Nee, das kann nicht euer Ernst sein.
Nee, das kann nicht sein.
Ich muss doch nicht das für jede Datei machen.
Nee, man kann garantiert den Default-Browser umstellen.
Choose Defaults bei Fire, Choose Defaults bei Link.
Ja, das sieht doch.
Nee, das kann nicht sein.
Muss doch in Default-Browser.
Hä?
Kann man keinen Default-Browser einstellen?
Lecke ich critical information?
Das ist wirklich so?
Windows 11, Change Default Apps.
Default-Browser, ja.
Auto-Change, die Tom's Guide.
Erzähl mir, wie es geht, ja.
Hier, Apps.
Also.
Apps, Default, Chrome.
Hä?
Das muss man wirklich so machen?
Wait a minute, das muss man.
Repeat Step For...
Ernsthaft?
Wirklich, Microsoft?
Seid ihr das Wahnsinns oder was?
Aller Monat SR.
Hatten die den Arsch offen oder was?
Weißt du wirklich?
Das ist komplett lost.
Was ist denn mit denen los, man?
Ich hab das nicht für möglich gehalten.
Geht es über die Chrome-Settings?
Ja, das funktioniert.
Aber vielleicht will ich es ja auch mal so umstellen, unabhängig von den Browser-Settings.
Oder vielleicht auch mal mein Standard-Media-Player oder sonst was.
Keine Ahnung.
Ist das schlecht, man?
Wegen Wetter.
Geht das vielleicht hier?
Bei Default-Link-Type?
Nee.
Ja, gut.
Doch, ein bisschen geht das.
Nein, ich will nicht Edge ausprobieren.
Chrome, Alter.
FDP.
Ja, will ich auch.
Auch Chrome.
Na ja, doch, so ein bisschen geht es anscheinend schon.
Meine Güte, meine Güte, Microsoft, please.
Komm an.
Also ich bin jetzt geneigt dazu, das Ganze, äh...
nicht zu installieren bis 2025, nachdem ich das gesehen habe.
Moin, Michael, 50 Billionen, schön, dass du auch wieder da bist.
Huge.
Chrome-Settings führt dorthin, wirklich?
Ich dachte in Chrome...
Nee, in Chrome kannst du oben anklicken, Mac-Default.
Default.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das in den Chrome-Settings überhaupt...
Ah, hier, Default-Browser.
Chrome ist hier Default-Browser, ja.
Probieren wir das mal mit Firefox aus.
Also, machen wir mal hier.
Install.
Firefox.
Gibt es nicht?
Hier, gibt es keinen Firefox in WinGet?
Nein.
belongs to you
Ach Mozilla-Firefox.
Da muss man schon korrekt sein.
Ja, die Lösung ist wirklich suboptimal.
Wir brauchen für alles Route-Rechte.
Wir sind wieder bei Windows-890 angelangt.
Wir machen einfach Default-Route und gut ist.
Am Schluss Windows noch via WSL zerstören.
ok firefox am start bamm ja bei so nem browser denke ich auch immer dran irgendwas abzuflexen
oder zu polieren yes pin taskbar make default browser ja das geht jetzt das können die
browser während dem install machen darkscene wenn ich jetzt chrome starte sagt chrome achtung ich
bin nicht ein default browser ja ok ach nee jetzt jetzt führt es mich wirklich dahin das
ist wirklich nichts nicht optimal nicht gut gelöst ganz im ernst das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht
doch chrome also eben hat sich chrome auch gesetzt zum default aber jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr was
auch immer keine ahnung ich will ich will ich will es gar nicht so genau wissen welche ich bin
die challenge installiert für jeden browser für jede endung einen anderen browser auf
fife hat vorschlag interessant gibt es noch irgendwas was ich ausprobieren soll also für
mich ist bisher echt das nervigste dass ich die symbole nicht angruppen kann das nervt
mich richtig aber man kann die suche jetzt ausblenden das ist ganz gut die musik die
macht mich ja wahnsinnig schnellst kaputt geht nicht löscht das jetzt gleich
also im moment die taskleiste links hin ja das muss ich noch das muss ich jetzt noch
mal ausprobieren taskleiste allein ach es geht bloß es geht bloß left und center ok
select the far corner also hier ja das ist das kenne ich aber ich finde die funktion nicht
sinnvoll req edit ist your friend nee das geht nicht über req edit da sind ja gerade das dumme
an der windows 11 taskleiste dass das nicht über req edit geht ach so ja du kannst du kannst über
jaja das geht du kannst die taskleiste verschieben nach links oder rechts also das das geht über
die registry tatsächlich aber dann geht es nicht richtig die taskleiste kann man die taskbar
positionieren das funktioniert auch nicht mehr bisher konntest du hier sagen unlock und dann
kannst du es rumschieben wie du willst aber haben die überhaupt was sinnvolles eingebaut
oder ist das alles irgendwie nur nerviger geworden da muss es doch sinnvolle sachen
geben also gut es gibt dass das gibt sinnvolle sachen es gibt beispielsweise neue virtualisierungs
funktionen für passwörter und security features das ist sinnvoll und es ist sicherlich auch die
ein oder andere sache unter der haube sinnvoll aber die ganzen optikgeschichten und ja ich
finde es auch nicht schlecht dass die system settings und diese sachen dass das ein bisschen
moderner ist ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr aus einem guss wobei es ja schon aufhört wenn
du die display settings gehst und etwa anste display informationen einstellen willst da
musst du hier wieder ins win 95 menü rein ja versuch mal win get mit minus minus silent
dann sollte das jui blockieren jetzt soll ich mal firefox installen minus minus silent man
jetzt kriege ich kein pop-up jetzt darf ich das pop-up von hand aufmachen das macht es
auch nicht besser macht eigentlich gesagt überhaupt kein unterschied feifei das ist die beste
funktion aller zeiten das leister auf dem zweiten monitor geht auch nicht ja das habe ich auch
gehört dass es nicht geht es ist anstrengend jetzt leute leute ich ich macht es weg ich brauche
platz ich brauche platz auf der disc ich brauche platz auf meiner platte sag du musst noch bf aufnehmen
ja deswegen gehe ich jetzt auch gleich auf das habe ich nie xp xp vm wenn aus xp warum habe
ich gewinnt aus xp vm das haben wir doch mal hier zusammen im streben rum gewurstet oder 24g ich
brauche platz ich brauche platz die muss weg remove okay alles weg mal gucken ob ich jetzt
wieder platz habe ja das sieht doch schon besser aus 173g huge poggers wunderbar
so ich nehme jetzt noch battlefield auf oder ich weiß nicht ob ich da nehme ich noch battlefield
auf ich doch auch morgen mittag nachmittag
den egon und die welt morgen früh videos hoch zu ja morgen streben ich auf jeden fall battlefield
best aller huge basten alle basten der frazier macht ja leider nicht mit
machs wie alt bist du ich bin 37 so ich hauste mal den cyrus was macht er denn ich glaube
new world spielens der einzige der online ist dem ich follow und er hat es auch verdient oder
wie wir raiden zack bäm der spielt new world raiden irgendwelche dinger wer new world interessiert
kann sich am angucken ich gehe jetzt auf nehmen vielleicht noch ein bisschen battlefield kram auf
und es war auf jeden fall schön dass sie im stream dabei gewesen seid richtig poggers dass
so viele leute sich spontan eingefunden haben dank für die ganzen subs ich gucke nach wer
subscribt hat nachdem ich gesagt habe ich überweist dass alles der katzenhilfe karlsruhe und ich muss
es aber erst einmal raussuchen könnt ihr euch darauf verlassen mache ich wirklich sagt es nicht
einfach nur so ich schreibe den dann morgen auch eine twitter message so nach dem motto ihr schönen
cruz vom chat was 30 leute ungefähr ja das ist doch schon mal dann rund ich mal auf 100 euro auf
sieht besser aus ist schlechter ja ist das fazit also wir sehen uns bis dann machs gut zu